good to be here little hungover runs in
the family my dad's a drinker although
my uncle he got his act together my
uncle is thirty years sober can believe
that thirty years sober yeah yeah the
other night I was like oh man I got so
drunk I lost my phone my uncle's like oh
yeah I did that once I was like wow you
know drunk you have to be to lose your
phone thirty years ago
holy hell are you telling me you got
hammered and lost a landline yeah I
don't know drink at least the fun stuff
you know I met the girlfriend one night
stand'
good time during the sex she kept
yelling out baby baby baby oh baby kept
saying baby over it over and again so I
yelled out relationship she was like
what the hell are you doing I was like
oh I thought were just yelling out stuff
we don't want
I know weird always say baby in bed
while were yelling out the thing we
don't want to happen you know you don't
do that with food chili dog
diarrhea weird baby how did baby get in
there it's like a sexy word baby right
because you can't be like a toddler I
don't know words are weird but it's got
to be tough to be a lady you know uh
friend of mine she's got cheated on by a
guy she's really mad she's like huh men
are dogs they're all dogs
that's a weird choice when a guy cheats
huh cuz aren't dogs literally the most
loyal animal you can do anything dogs
stick with you hit a woman kill a kid
dogs like he's home you know if anything
guys who cheat her more like cats he'll
they're all nervous freaking out head on
a swivel all right where were you last
night yeah I don't know sometimes wish I
was gay that seems pretty good I used to
live with a gay guy he seemed to have it
all figured out you know gay guys can
get away with more actually got let go
from a job once for sexual harassment I
told a woman she had nice legs they
fired me which really bothered me cuz my
gay friends at work got away with murder
the big hey Shelly how are you Hong Kong
like laughs why is that okay like wilt
they're not attracted to women I was
like so what I'm not attracted to kids I
can't go to a playground hey Timmy I
[Applause]
don't get stuff like that you know all
right like you're a woman when you
rather be complimented by a group that's
into you I don't care for lesbian
complements me nothing against lesbian
but I didn't help my ego yeah
lesbians like hey Mark like your haircut
I'm like I now have the same one I don't
know is that offensive I I can't tell
what's offensive anymore we've we've
ruined that word you know I don't know I
was at a Starbucks recently this guy
gave my coffee I went hey thanks chief
this guy goes ooh
don't say chief that's offensive the
Native Americans I was like how is that
offensive he goes whoa don't say how
I don't know I I don't know I have no
hatred towards any group I just you know
I just like the words
who's got the energy be racist who's got
the time put on an outfit go to a
meeting oh I don't care I don't care
about any group enough to hate it go
nuts do whatever you want I have no
opinions hey you hear these guys like
that what about these Muslims on
airplanes I'm like well I'd rather a
Muslim on a plane than a baby yeah that
a hundred percent better experiences
with Muslims and children I'm just
saying the airport had a baby band I
wouldn't protest everybody's up an arse
about something these days
transgender that's the big one now
transgender using the bathrooms well
they're still using toilets right
they're not leaving a hot floater in the
sink yeah that was the case yeah we
should ever talk I'm trying to wash my
hands here put that in the toilet then
you get the hillbilly guy well what if
one of these perverts puts on a dress
and looks at my wife in the bathroom oh
what a score some guy can see your fat
wife taking a dump what a lucky guy come
on go to work you lunatic we've come a
long way in this country you know come a
long way like you know in the 50s we had
whites only and blacks only water
fountains which is incredibly sad
especially if you're thirsty Asian
yeah what the hell were they doing know
whatever talked about when they drink
out of a hose never her to think about
it yeah black people are angry can you
believe this we got our own water
fountain aged like can I get a sip I'm
dying out here
Hayes you're smart to hang back they
Waverly I'll wait for black people might
put a fight then we'll take the
convenience stores I don't know a lot of
racial talk these days white privilege
that's a term I hear a lot now white
privilege I was at a gross store
recently with a friend of mine he's
black I stole a candy bar I love this
deal I got a rush deal I got outside I'm
all proud of myself my friend goes white
privilege white privilege I was like wow
no this was a robbery
if I gotten caught and gotten away with
it that would be white privilege this is
me being an amazing thief and he was
like now now now it's white privilege
the guy didn't fly around the store he
followed me around the store and I was
like well yeah that's why I brought you
[Applause]
you